how important was that record yoko for
you man because that was a you know that
record also went to radio right and i
think you had a bag going for that
record you had big crit chris brown whiz
was that the first record you and wizard
did
um
that was 2010 right
i think that that is the first wiz
song yeah it was
it was a big record for me and i think
that like there's a story behind that
[ __ ] that no one even knows about
what not just like the making of the
video was wild like
when i did that song
i ran into chris brown in the studio
right he was there i was smoking bud his
cousin smoked the bug was like oh shot
[ __ ] would you come meet brown got brown
in the video back then his manager was
tina davis she said all right well he
will prove him doing the record we
cannot do any video like video is not
happening wow whatever
um so
i got the record done whiz big crit
chris brown
big [ __ ] made the beat [ __ ] was tech i
was like i gotta do a video for this
i was getting that brown's cousin he was
like look if you want to get chris to
come out you got to bring something dope
like he got hella cars he likes to drive
his cars like think of a way you can
have him go provide an area for you know
for him to spin out in his cars or
something like come with something i'll
pitch it to him like all right cool so i
was thinking like maybe i can get a race
car track and so i called that a nascar
place in irvine or whatever the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was
and uh i asked him how much it was and i
said well what do you want to do i said
tomorrow he's like no like it's not
happening i'm like okay well how much is
it he's like well how much you got i'm
like i got 1500 he laughed at me
it's like man like um
we wouldn't even run out the parking lot
for less than 15 g's and you want to use
the [ __ ] race track i'm sorry buddy
it's not happening i'm like what can i
come see you in person
he's like if you want to hear no to your
face come through i'm like for sure so i
pulled up over there
i met this guy square dude square ass
[ __ ] old dude
i was like yo um you know i'm here to
you know say yeah i don't really know
what to tell you kid you know it's not
happening i told you going here no to
your face
no
okay can you just do me one favor he's
like what i'm gonna go to your computer
he's like all right
i pull up with khalifa
on youtube and look at his views look at
his like all right so i'm like go to
chris brown look at his views
pulls up he looks at the views he's like
if this is about like you think you're
gonna give me promo look outside i got
coca-cola i got pepsi got all these
places paying me money to be on my wall
i'm like it's not about that let me
finish go type in burner look at my
views typed in burner i'm like you see
the difference
am i bro like this guy ain't going to
come do this video if i don't think of
something and i only have one day so if
you provide me this spot you can change
my life bro straight up but i just had
to hear a no in person bro so i
appreciate you and the dude was like you
know what
come here tomorrow save your 1500 bring
five for the ambulance and you could use
my racetrack i appreciate you coming
here i appreciate you telling me why you
why it was important to you and i'll let
you use the place like cool
so i leave
and we show up the next day
this guy's daughter was the biggest fan
of chris brown ever i guess he went home
and told her this guy brought down the
[ __ ] race car drivers that did the
video for otis for jay-z and conway what
this guy brought out [ __ ]
semi-fucking 18-wheeled trucks spin it
out in the video right
straight 150 000 production value at
least right let me do my thing there
brown pulled up the energy was crazy you
see them scrambling around bro i only
spent 500 for that [ __ ] bro
on everything i love
on everything i love right like that
[ __ ] was crazy as [ __ ]
and then you see the scene where um
i'm driving the 18-wheeler
bro i went to atlanta and i went to
every i went to every truck stop where
all the truckers were resting and
knocked on [ __ ] doors
and had a thousand dollars and tried to
convince the driver to let me drive his
[ __ ] they called the cops on me twice i
finally got some cuddy nigerian dude was
like whatever you got a thousand bucks
it's yours i don't even know how to
drive people don't even know this i
don't even know how to drive
a [ __ ] car
oh you don't drive no
i drive a boat i'm driving a [ __ ] car
so i was let alone a [ __ ] uh semi the
guy was laying on the ground with his
foot on the [ __ ] guys holding the
pedal i'm sitting there riding in the
[ __ ] freeway bro
[ __ ] riding this [ __ ] rapping and the
guy is sweating dude like oh my god sir
we're done we're done i'm like nah nah
one more thing one more scene so that
video was hella crazy to me it's hella
important to me
now atlantic records put a cease and
desist on it for whatever reason which
makes no sense to me so it's not
available anymore but
it was big bro
i didn't that that that's crazy it's not
on youtube no it is but it's not the one
i put up with all the millions of views
someone like ripped it and put it on
their own channel or something yeah
that was was that and that was prior to
you being officially tailor gang correct
well it got it got pulled it got pulled
out when i was with taylor gang because
some dude um
i'm gonna say his name some dude took
the song and tried to do some licensing
deal with someone in [ __ ] europe and
the atlanta got pissed and [ __ ]
pulled it but
you know whatever